NARRATOR: South Africa's Western
Cape is notoriously dangerous.
Almost one in four of all
fatal great white attacks
happen here.
In other parts of the world,
the most dangerous time
to enter the water is at
dawn or dusk, the times when
white sharks typically hunt.
But these waters are different.
Investigators have
identified that the majority
of the attacks on the Western
Cape take place during the day.
This surprising anomaly
could be the key to solving
the mystery behind the attacks.
Mike Barron is a marine
biologist living in Cape Town.
For the past two
years, he's been
studying the oceanic
ecosystems of the Western Cape.
Mike believes part
of the answer lies
in an incredible aspect of
South Africa's marine ecology.
MIKE BARRON: So today,
we're going to drop down
and I'm going to monitor one
of my favorite places to dive.
It's a really amazing,
magical place.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: These are South
Africa's kelp forests.
Each strand of
this giant seaweed
measures up to 40 feet tall
and grows in dense clusters
stretching over
600 miles, Creating
a vast, underwater wonderland.
MIKE BARRON: All the
different complexities
of life down there,
and it's a fantastic
area to dive and research.
NARRATOR: The kelp
forests are home
to all manner of oceanic life.
But there is one
species that lives here
of particular
significance when it comes
to sharks, cape fur seals.
MIKE BARRON: White
sharks are often
seen patrolling the
edges of kelp forests
looking for the cape fur seal.
NARRATOR: Until recently, it
was believed that great whites
patrolled the edges of the
kelp forests at dawn and dusk,
but rarely ventured in.
The sun's low
position in the sky
was thought to
help them pick out
the silhouettes of
unsuspecting seals
as they exited the forest.
But in 2019, a study
emerged that turned
traditional thinking about
great whites' hunting patterns
on its head.
MIKE BARRON: In 2019,
researchers were conducting
a study on great white sharks.
They attached some cameras
to the dorsal fins,
and the footage that came
back was very unusual.
That actually found that these
sharks were moving into quite
dense forest areas,
and even hunting
seals, which
previously we thought
was not happening at all.
NARRATOR: And most
importantly, the sharks
were seen to be
hunting during the day,
not just at dawn and dusk.
MIKE BARRON: This new
revelation in shark research
means that all the way through
today, wherever there's kelp,
there's potentially
white sharks cruising
around, looking for their seal.
NARRATOR: South Africa
is one of a few countries
in the world that
has natural kelp
forests right on its coast.
MIKE BARRON: Kelp grows
all along the beaches
here in the Western Cape,
right from the intertidal zone
and very highly populated
beaches as well.
There's lots of people
swimming, surfing,
and diving in the forests
right along the coast.
NARRATOR: This means that every
day at any time, the sharks
are patrolling the coastline
of the Western Cape,
looking for seals, in the exact
same waters used by people.